another taboo is to celebrate European
culture multiculturalists get pretty
unhappy when europeans start expressing
pride in their culture or heritage many
especially on the left do not draw much
of a distinction at least in practice
between European pride and white
supremacy you care about freedom of the
individual the individuals freedom to
think to speak to associate in short to
act as he sees fit without external
compulsion as long as he doesn't
infringe on the similar liberties of
others
professor Ricardo duchesne a historical
sociologist and professor at the
University of New Brunswick argues that
quote individualism is a unique
attribute of European peoples quote it
has been exported to some degree to
other nations but in my view it is not
something that comes to them naturally
so he continues quote you can't play the
game of we're all individuals we have to
affirm and be proud of our ethnic
identity and heritage to preserve the
West's curious individualism
if Europeans become minorities in the
West he argues the founding idea of the
West that no entity not an individual
not a community not the state can justly
deprive an individual of life liberty or
property by force no matter what the
individuals race class or religion I
wouldn't be surprised if Duchene when he
made this statement had you in mind
look the medieval Europeans identified
seven deadly sins for a reason and one
of them was pride it's like let's make
the presumption I do believe that for
for reasons that aren't obvious that the
West has got some things right we've got
the sovereignty of the individual right
that's the most fundamental thing we've
got right we've articulated that I think
you know in a remarkable weight not only
theologically philosophically in our
body of law
in our societies and one of the
consequences of that as its had its
effect on the rest of the world is that
everyone is getting richer quite fast
and that's a really good thing okay
having said that it's like am i proud of
that it's like I didn't do that what the
hell
pride what's that that's not the right
response
how about responsibility for that how
would that be it's like you're part of
this is great and unlikely set of
propositions this strange set of
propositions that says that in some
ineffable manner the poorest person is
as valuable as the king it's like how
the hell did we ever figure that out
that's an impossible thing to think and
yet that's the that's the bedrock of our
legal system that's nothing to be proud
of that's something to tremble before to
take on as a an ethical burden and not
to wave a flag for how wonderful you are
that you happen to have the same skin
color as some of the people who thought
that up it's not the right response it's
like it's it's to open your eyes and
recognize that as a miracle and a
relatively relatively new miracle on the
world stage and to and to participate in
the process of upholding that in your
personal and your public life that's not
pride in European tradition like when I
go to Europe and I love going to Europe
and the European cities are there are
unbelievable masterpieces which is why
they're completely flooded by pilgrims
right
tourists pilgrims who go there to look
at the beauty so I don't feel pride
about that I feel I feel like I have
something to live up to that's not the
same thing man and so these
right-wingers and this it's like look
what we've done it's like no it's not
you that did that that's something man
you got to you're going to have your act
together before you would dare to say
well that was me it's like yeah sure
sure it was you Yeah right
no that's hard to stand up and take your
place in that in that kind of historical
process that unlikely miraculous
historical process no
to just feel ashamed at the way that
you're presently constituted in the face
of that means that you're you're deluded
and you're using your your your great
fortune of being a beneficiary of that
system look at what we've got here this
great piece that we're inhabiting right
now you're using your unearned the
unearned gift that's been granted to you
as a source of personal pride in your
accomplishments due to your skin it's
like no not good not a good argument so
and that doesn't mean that while there's
nothing valuable about European culture
there's plenty there's plenty about it
that's value it's not even so clear to
what degree it's European I mean it came
out of the Middle East you know I mean
who it's so muddle-headed that you
hardly know where to start